we need to settle a little controversy
little controversy there was a picture
oh you've probably seen this it was on
the internet and in papers and things
and it's this picture here now oh yeah
people people were trying to decide if
that was Bill Murray or Tom Hanks well
I've been doing a pale imitation of Bill
Murray for most Americans actually works
out I know that it's not me because I
did not take that picture look I've had
a cranial plates shift that you know as
a medicinal eye that's not me actually
even looking at you not you dude doesn't
know yeah I could make that face thing
where you have you you think you've got
sides oh I do
oh we all know what our good side is
I'll show it if you can come close okay
let in a hideously embarrassing close
okay all right I will show you right now
should I start with the good side of the
bed good side
really yeah okay okay this this is my
good side now I don't know why but I
have a I have a jaw and I have a chin
and I have a you know back at the flat
it actually could you come around sort
of like 3/4 ish a little bit okay there
okay yeah okay there there is that it
come in a little tighter please little
tighter all right so far we're still
doing okay it's all right
it's not bad all right now stay there
and just watch this nut goes away
but note if he comes as a malformed
thing and put about half a cheek
sticking out so I think you like kind of
go from Richard Gere to Richard Nixon
[Applause]
when you do a photo shoot
do you favor outside uh-huh I I think
this is my better side but then then we
can never work together we must leave we
can marry grant in Rosslyn muscle come
today
what about yourself Jesse are you aware
of a side ah should I be no I don't tell
me when I'm willing to vote yo let's go
to the next to the look get over
okay well let's bite goodbye applause
only okay alright okay
liking it
[Applause]
we just thought while you're here to to
settle things to avoid confusion in the
future we might be in act that oh you
have an orange jumper I do I do have
some I absolutely Col soon oh great I've
got some orange things there now Gemma
would you mind being a the money she's
the mother of the baby so there's some
sunglasses there and that would you mind
being the baby yeah we that you oh you
can do that would you actually that's
better this that's better why don't we
think of that okay so I'm like here down
in that downtown you go there you go
squeeze in squeeze in right like that
smiling
graham norton air if you'd like to see
even more stuff like that that hit
subscribe or don't it's a free world but
I know what I do in that situation